very much for turning up my talk it's
almost full house uh it's pretty amazing
thank you very much again
i would like to start my talk
uh with a
quote from
18th century uh prussian general and
military theorists from klaushevitz
machine learning is the continuation of
software engineering by other means
we are going to see in this presentation
that we can borrow a lot from software
engineering applied to machine learning
to make ourselves more productive
the title of my talk is clean
architecture how to structure your ml
projects to reduce technical debt
first of all we are going to see how
technical debt ruins
your productivity uh we will look at why
machine learning products particularly
prone to collect technical debt and a
couple of relevant software engineering
concepts um
like decoupling refactoring and design
patterns to help yourself
avoid this
about me
about me
but my past i have a finance background
mobile gaming
and i was head of data science at a
london fintech startup
now i teach data scientists to write
better code
also i am a
startup consultant please check out my
blog at laszlo.substance.com
um
what do we mean by ml products it's
important to
sorry for uh why is it um
should i
give it a try
okay
cool sorry uh
i was just
mixed up and so let's look at what do we
mean by ml products it's important to
understand that mlops is not a ml
product mlops is an infrastructure that
you are using to facilitate
ml products and it's also not data
analyzes
data analyzers have a fixed starting
point when you are gathering the data
and then it has a relatively short
period of lifetime when you are handing
back your
results to the stakeholders
even that applies if you're using
machine learning techniques in advanced
analytics situation that still not
create an ml product
um ml products are complex business
processes that are usually described by
input output relationships
end to end
and they work usually autonomously they
don't require particular amount of
manual work
to to facilitate the operation
and they usually have a long lifespan
and one of the reasons why
dealing with technical debt refactoring
investing into quality code is a highled
activity because you can yield this back
over a long period of time over the
entire lifecycle of this ml product
what does technical that why does
technical that matter um ml products
usually solve complicated business
processes
that are very fuzzy in nature they're
not described by rules they are
described by edge cases
and ad hoc rule of thumbs and
this is why usually rule-based systems
are not a good baseline for machine
learning products and they are also
inherently unspecifiable it means that
no matter how careful you are specifying
your ml product there is going to be
aspects of the work and features that
you are going to find out about
while your product is in production why
because of the fuzzy nature of every
business process you know if it would be
easy to specify you can write rules and
these rules would solve your problem
and not only that but also um
they need continuous updates you know
the the context uh they are operating
changes the environment the business
needs are changing uh you know this is
particularly important in data drift uh
so you need to by definition prepare for
change
and changing creates a technical debt
let's take a look at the ml lifecycle
and how that impacts data
take that in machine learning products
um
classically there is five steps of an ml
lifecycle
you have eda like explorer data analyzes
when you are concerned about the data
proof of concept when you are concerned
about the models
in the mvp stage you are doing
productionization
and fine tuning in a b testing and
classically you think of business as
usual as um
as
an important place for monitoring so why
this is a not a particularly good
structure and often the first two steps
are not even done by the same people
than the rest you know the first two
steps are done by data scientists
and then from the productionization is
done by machine learning engineers the
translation between them creates a
friction
that is slowing down the iteration speed
when you are analyzing a b tests you
know these are necessarily fed back to
the early stages uh because only the
data scientists are able to collate this
knowledge into one place they need to
take this knowledge and update the
machine learning engineers to update the
project this is a
high friction uh technique
the
and
which unable to run at a high speed
iteration
which means that changes can accumulate
before they are translated into
production which means that two steps of
the same version we're gonna go further
away from each other um and that means
that uh sooner or later uh each version
update they're gonna be a big deal and
it can create a business continuity
problem so it means that you need to
plan for it and it's even longer
and often what you see in machine
learning products is instead of setting
up a continuous integration or a
continuous update pipeline rather they
just scratch the previous version and
then write a new one from scratch you
know this is clearly not an agile
way of solving problem which we know
that it is fuzzy in nature and changing
as we go along
uh what's a different difference between
technical uh debt and technical mass
so
uh it's a it's a specific term for for
what you sometimes experience
it's important that lack of
specification documentation and
infrastructure is not
technical that you are just haven't
finished particular aspects of your work
it's also not missing features you know
if you are missing something you just
need to add it you don't um
address that as technical that and it's
also not broken models if your model is
is drifting you know you just need to
update it
and that that's the right term for that
it is uh drifted and most importantly it
is not bad practice uh technical debt
and referring to certain practices as
creating technical debt is not a license
to create bad practice and it's a very
important
term to use technical mess for these
expressions uh because it otherwise the
technical debt would give you a license
to get away for doing
technical mess so what is technical that
technical debt is an attempt to gain
knowledge with a plan to correct it
later um just like when you are uh
getting into that
and
here i would refer to corporate that not
credit card that credit card that is off
is always a a
bad idea but corporate debt
is a natural way of facilitating a
business with if you have a plan to pay
it back you know if you don't have a
plan to pay ben then it's just
recklessness you know you're just not a
prudent
a way to run a business
evart cunningham who
coined the phrase technical that said
that painting back that depends on
writing code clean enough to be
refactored
and let's take a look at what
refactoring means
refactoring means changing the code
without changing its behavior
why would you
do that why would you change the code
without changing its behavior
we know that everything can be solved
multiple ways in computer science
why do you think that the first solution
is the best solution that you can come
up with
so often the way you
solve problems in computer sciences that
first you solve this problem and then
you transfer this solution in a way that
can
enable
the solution of future problems and the
maintainability and this is exactly the
purpose of refactoring is turning the
an existing code an existing solution
into something which is nicer it
requires two
steps it needs fast testing
it means that you need to have an easy
way to verify that the change what you
did just to the code
didn't break
that code and it also requires
what's called experimental operational
symmetry
eos for short
which we are going to see
why is it important
so what is eos
is google's fancy name for running the
same code everywhere and this is you can
see that in the traditional machine
learning life cycle when the data
scientist and the machine learning
engine is not using the same code this
is this is the principle that is broken
um this enables refactoring um
so the same code where do you run the
same code you run it on your laptop uh
you're running in testing
training evaluation and production
but it's always the the same code and it
requires uh two things so it enables
refactoring um but it requires something
called decoupling what is decoupling
um clearly on your laptop you don't have
the same resources as in a cloud
infrastructure or a distributed
architecture so somehow needs to be able
to run this code without
certain features existing
and decoupling
is the paradigm to
remove um
the reduce the dependency between
components of your architecture
um it allows you to with interfaces to
hide implementation details of the
peripherals so these peripherals can
change without impacting the the the
core of your problem
and
this also helps you to break a cake
which is changing anything changes
everything which is a particular pro
problem for machine learning
how do you achieve this decoupling you
can imagine your machine learning
product is defined as a class this is
what you see in the the blue box
and it requires two decoupling steps one
first of is inversion of control
the second one is dependency injection
what is inversion of control
in traditionally uh when you write a
code
you think of your code as running um and
it calls infrastructure
services
this is a direct control inversion of
control tells you that the
infrastructure calls instantiates your
product as a class and then calls the
main entry point and this is what you
see in the
in the the image um
why is it good because it means that the
running code doesn't is not aware of uh
whether it runs in an infrastructure or
in a test infrastructure
and therefore you achieve decoupling
from
wherever you run the code
you also decouple with dependency
injection from
external interfaces for databases or
external services
this
happens through adapter classes and we
are going to see a couple of examples
later in the talk
so in the test environment you are using
the same code you are instantiated in
the test hardness and call the main
entry point by the test setup
and replace the adapters
with connections that connect to
temporary services that allows you to
verify whether your code did the same
thing as it would have done in
production
and passes the the test setups uh
inside your code how do you structure um
and every kind of machine learning
product has um
some kind of business problem at its
center this is why i draw
into the buzzer the business
problem and this is surrounded by a
business-specific
terminology
domain model so for example if you deal
with customers you know you have a
customer class if you deal with
transactions then you have a transaction
class
or anything that is using the same
language as your business uses it means
that
um
at this point you can
communicate with this without
translation you know if you have data
frames and column names and sql queries
it's much harder to talk to a subject
matter experts
if you um don't use the same language
and obvious this is true for the
business languages this is surrounded by
the machine learning specific
techniques like data sets or training or
evaluation and only this
outer layer is connected to the
infrastructure which is like databases
or computing infrastructure this have
the additional benefit of
outsourcing these to other teams and
cooperating with other
technical teams at the company
because obviously
these are decoupled from your main
problem so it means that you can just
outsource them and they can work with
you much more efficiently while you can
focus all your attention to the
to the center uh to the actual machine
learning product that is where you are
adding most of the value
how does it happen when you see the
previous uh
image images you see moving from um the
infrastructure to the test structure
here you can see the same thing in clean
architecture how do you swap the
out test layer to
temporary structures that enables to run
the same code
in a much smaller
place and
still
do it
efficiently
and how do we actually implement that so
we are going to look at three simple
design patterns which is essentially
doing the same thing
how do you handle dependency injection
for three particular states the adapter
pattern which you have already seen
allows you to decouple from external
services and the factory pattern allows
you to decouple
data sources
and the strategy pattern allows you to
decouple yourself from algorithmic
decisions which is particularly
important in machine learning because
usually you try to
[Music]
experiment with different
[Music]
algorithmic decisions and you still need
to maintain some kind of coherence in
your solutions and don't need to rewrite
your entire code base for every problem
you do
so let's take a look
at the code is it visible
can you read it
okay
so you can see that the code has already
been refactored into
a class
and the infrastructure which is now a
shell script
uh instantiates this class and calls the
main entry point so you can see that
inversion of control is uh is already
implemented so what does this code do it
creates a
database connection and then goes to
that database run an sql query um and
get the data uh into a data frame
what's the problem with this obviously
if you're running it locally on your
machine and you don't have access to
this database that this is code will not
gonna run if you change this code um
you know you have no idea whether you
didn't break it you know
so what you can do
clearly the problem is that the main
function is aware of the existence of a
database that is may or may not be
present so essentially you move all of
the code into a separate class which is
named sql source
and the main class only knows the
existence of a source which has an
interface called get data and this get
data we're going to give you that data
frame but the main program doesn't know
where is this data coming from and you
can see that
now the infrastructure instantiates the
main program with this source
and if you want to run it in a test
structure you can replace only this sql
source with a let's say file based class
and do the same thing and run it again
the next one is a factory pattern so we
see in the previous query that the query
is concerned about customers
but instead of a customer you are
getting back a data frame which is not a
domain specific class so what do would
you do
let's do another refactoring step when
instead of
a nondescript technical implementation
like a pandas data frame you are getting
back domain specific classes and the
rest of your
code can depend on something which is
the same as you talk to uh the subject
matter expert
and you can see that in
the the last line you are using um the
same um
instantiation instead of the the sql
database you are
instantiating a domain specific data
source
let's take a look at the last pattern
what we i'm going to talk about is
a strategy pattern which is classic uh
problem that happens in a lot of machine
learning products um this is the same
situation
a customer class is transformed into
features
and that's fed to a logistic regression
which
creates a prediction what's the problem
with this is that obviously if you would
like to replace and use a different
model and do an experiment you need to
rewrite your main code you know this can
be entangled several places
which means that
anytime you change the code you are
risking that you are going to break
something
you would like to have this version
running and another version with a
different model running at the same time
as well and make sure that you change
the less amount of what you can do is
you can move all of this code into a
specific function strategy pattern is
just an externalization of an
algorithmic dependency and you can see
that the main code now only deals with
a model predict interface it doesn't
know what kind of model it was calling
it means that you can replace with
whatever model you want if you want to
have random fresh you can instantiate
that here down you need to write another
class and your main program will going
to run in the same way if they have the
same interface right this is a one of
the most used
design patterns in machine learning
applications
the strategy pattern also have another
important driving force which is called
coherence um essentially let's say on
the left-hand side you can see that here
is a deep model which has layers and
obviously in instantiation i specify
that i need five layers for this model
this information that it has five layers
is
put into the constructor and then passed
on to in the main function to
instantiate a model with with five
layers what's the problem here if you
would like to use a different type of
model that doesn't have layers what do
you need to do you need to rewrite every
place where i was
was specifying these layers
instead if you use a strategy pattern
you externalize this information
in the construction you are only passing
this information to the model itself and
the main code is not aware of um
of what kind of model it is running um
and
the code is more compact and the it is
at the place where it is supposed to be
if you replace this model to let's say
you use random forest which has a number
of trees as a parameter um you don't
need to change your main code again um
while at the same time you are
maintaining the old version as well
because obviously this is just one line
to change this
so how does a general workflow
look when you start from scratch usually
you define your data classes
based on the specification this is
usually coming out when
you're talking to subject matter experts
of what kind of problems your machine
learning product needs to solve
and then you wrap your data sources with
the factories that are creating these
data classes
and you only deal with these data
classes in the rest of your machine
learning product
then you set up a test environment
one of the fastest way to do that is to
create functional tests with like a
small amount of the data what you need
to use you run your entire pipeline with
0.1 percent
of the data sets or whatever you think
that is enough to ensure that the
changes of the code is um
saved then you define your interfaces
these are usually the verbs so the data
classes are usually the nouns the verbs
are you know do or get or create or all
of this and then collect these
interfaces into service classes if you
are thinking about your product let's
say a micro services architecture then
these service classes is like the proto
abstraction of a service that is going
to be a standalone program in the future
or not you know
you don't know whether refactoring will
going to eliminate some of these
services
and once you have done that then you can
start dependency injection uh with uh
like you structure your code you move
the right places to the uh usually you
collect quite a considerable amount of
technical debt uh on this uh because
this is a the first part is a very
evolutionary step
so the structuring and the dependence
injection we're going to help you to
increase the coherence and create
optionality for you
to go to production
then you wrap your external services
with adapters um
doing the same interface that you were
using previously with the in the test
environment and then you can set up the
production environment namely
instantiating your product with the
adapters that connects you to the um
the real world and
then you can create experiments with a
strategy pattern uh because that's what
it is purpose that without destroying
the production environment you can
create other contexts where you can run
these experiments and solve these
problems
obviously most of you work in
notebooks like us
so how does this work with
in a notebook environment
we usually load because the factories
are classes themselves you can
instantiate them and get the data
to get the data classes in notebooks and
then we turn these data classes into
data frames and do any kind of analysis
on that
and then the other thing what you can do
is you can create custom experiments
by
instantiating main program the main
program itself is a class which you can
create inside your notebook
and then you can create experiments in
your notebook with a strategy pattern to
a certain extent obviously dependent on
where your notebook server is running
what are the benefits we found that
there is good layers of abstraction
in in this structure you have a one
place where you do analyzes in notebooks
you have one place where you are writing
your production code which is in vs code
and then you can outsource a lot of the
infrastructure problems or
allocate you know time box time for
dealing with how do you write adapters
and what do you do with them
but you can
externalize these problems it gives you
a high level of flexibility
you are able to change your code and
back out of it so that's a very
important um
you know a productivity tool um in
in machine learning where you usually do
high-risk experiments um and you don't
want to accidentally ruin your code i'm
sure everyone did it before i'm plenty
of time when i regretted changing my
code and
it also have managed complexity
we found that machine learning problems
are inherently complex
you cannot have simple solutions it's
that they don't exist you don't simply
you don't try simple solutions you are
managing complex solutions uh and this
allowables you through the decoupling
and the externalization of
infrastructure problems and it enables
high speed iteration because you have
the same code running in every places
you have only one version of it
it means that when you change it and you
know that it didn't break this change
and you have a cascade of test suits
that we are going to validate that this
isn't going to go into production and
it's not going to break anything
then you can
reach
you know high-speed iteration
so let's
go through this again so we see that
machine learning is inherently
unspecifiable
that makes technical that inevitable
and you need refactoring to remove this
technical that
you can't have refactoring without
testing and eos to have eos you need
decoupling
to decouple you need you can do it
through clean architecture and inversion
of control and dependence injection and
you only you can achieve this by three
small
design patterns called adapters
factory and
strategy um and thank you very much for
your attention this concludes my talk uh
please subscribe to my blog this was a
very short amount of introduction to
this
concept
and i write regularly about it
thank you very much
thank you very much leslie we've got
some time for questions
um given the high amount of data frame
usage within more machine learning and i
guess
python and data analysis in general uh
given these
patterns as well how do you feel about
my pie and typing to kind of conform to
interfaces and make sure that
i don't know say a technical person
who's implementing say the adapters that
the person is actually using them
actually conforms to them and they
actually uses them because i didn't see
any of that uh yeah i didn't use typing
yeah yeah i would think um okay so
data scientists are a bit reluctant to
care about their software engineering
skills i'm sure you experienced that um
or philosophy like this is obviously an
advocacy and evangelism of this to data
scientists and we try to use the least
amount of moving components to teach in
one go
i would consider typing to a optional
with the caveat of
obviously it's a corporate policy or an
engineering policy whether you demand it
or not and i i do i do see usefulness in
that
but i do think it is optional
that makes sense and
i do think that you should
minimize your data frame usage outside
of analytics
thank you for the talk uh one
consequence of dependency injection is
now you need to manage the bootstrapping
just to provision all this i do the
actual injection for your system
and i feel that you might be pushed the
complexity to that part and python being
a dynamic language it can
be really hard to to to
achieve this because you might break
something without you realize uh you
might break the specification the
interface without realize you have also
broken the um the bootstrappings how do
you manage that
yes very good question um
i think
you need to have testing you know it
managing complex systems is not going to
be simpler just because we use one
technique or another um you still need
to
write enough tests um and usually
deal with enough edge cases to resolve
this problem
do you answer did i answer the question
so it's more about
the
bootstrapping is the because if you look
at the slide of the the example of the
uh dependence injection yeah uh you
there's a part in uh in in the main in
the main logic to actually inject the
object into it yeah so uh potentially
because you dependence can be can go
really deep it can be a long chain yeah
so how do you manage the complexity of
that with efficiency
interesting
i i don't know
let's take this offline right
hi thank you great talk
i wanted to understand what you think
about the usage of jupiter notebooks and
if you think that it's an
anti-pattern
in
machine learning projects
i would think that
um
we found that it is usually very like
there was just a talk before this who
showed relatively a lot of
infrastructure to manage um
[Music]
notebooks in in like a verified
environment uh and this i think it's a
sign that um you know
if you have all your relevant code in
you know in pure code and then you just
use notebooks for analysis then then
it's a better pattern
and
we only use um
data frames
in notebooks for analytical reasons but
everything else is in domain specific
classes
thank you
how do you deal with unit testing
a
machine learning algorithm which is
inherently stochastic and for example
i've worked with data scientists who
have written a unit test where they
basically ran the algorithm
dumped the output of the
resulting data frame and then
their test compares it
the the next run with that to 10 decimal
places yeah and that seems worse than no
test at all
that's what we do as well yeah um
obviously within reason the goal here um
we spent actually quite a lot of time on
figuring out and kent beck said that
when he worked for facebook facebook was
not doing testing and
ken beck was like the original
test-driven development guy and then he
had this kind of existential crisis of
how is it possible that one of the most
successful company in the world doesn't
follow his principles and still you know
thrives
and it means that
if you can verify your code that it does
what it did before after changing then
you are good so find something to test
and and this is what we do you know
running the the anti pipeline on a small
amount of data
so that's one problem
the second
is
machine learning we found that
the engineering style testing for
statistical problems is just not
feasible and you always end up
in some kind of analytical state
where essentially you're running the
entire pipeline and data scientists just
stare at these numbers
for days to trying to figure out whether
the change latest change in a in a model
was having the intended effect or not
and these are enough to verify that
major break points not didn't happen so
that's that's our workflow in terms of
testing
so this kind of small amount of data
testing is literally just testing
whether your code is not broken you know
because it will going to fail relatively
easy
okay so so do you distinguish between
not broken and not giving the right
results exactly exactly because it's so
difficult to specify i mean that's
exactly why you're using a machine
learning algorithm because you you have
no unit test would require relatively
simple rules
for
defining your system with through the
specification and that that's the very
nature why you are not why you're not
the software engineers haven't solved
this problem with software engineering
technique that's why you ended up on
your table okay thank you
hi
thanks for the talk so my original
question was regarding the factory
pattern and how you replace the data
frame with
a customer class or whatever is domain
relevant
and my question was yes but if we want
to have a performant operation we need
to vectorize it so effectively whoever
is going to operate on that customer
whatever abstraction is has to have a
vectorized operation which is panda
specific so we haven't really decoupled
anything yeah and i guess your answer
now would be don't use pandas
[Laughter]
so
i would like one thing only if your
answer is don't use pandas my follow-up
question is how can you justify losing
that performance because like i did
exactly what you did in your code
sometime in the past and then it became
so slow that i had to go back and use
pandas again
yeah okay very good question i do think
that
um first of all um
like obviously this is a generic advice
and um performance optimization is very
targeted so you need to identify the
place which is exactly the slowest one
and i would actually use strategy
pattern to wrap this and then somehow
isolate this kind of complicatedness um
of figuring out how to do that so that's
one one technique what we use we use a
lot of number if you need to
perform do performant coding um and any
kind of hackery hide it away behind this
kind of strategy there is there is a
quote called um
wrap your
difficult decisions in a class you know
and this is exactly when you end up that
i must break readability or
maintainability in terms of for
achieving some kind of feasible
performance improvement
um that's a difficult decision and you
need to isolate it and
make sure that it you achieve the goal
what you want but you know these are not
you know iron laws you know
please feel free to break them at any
point you want
any other questions
no okay
so
thank you for the talk there are a lot
of tools already in the
open source community
what do you think about
cookie
cutter the data science cookie cutter in
term of
clean architecture and how can you
combine it with the whole thing with
head on system
i would i would see that these are
parallel things cookie cutter is mostly
for structuring your
your project profile
if i remember correctly um
this is more like
like structuring your the abstract
structuring your code you know the
product itself and not the physical
location of the files but these are are
parallel to each other
great uh well if no one has any more
questions uh yeah we can finish the
launch thanks again lastly